[Music]
[Applause]
he's Devonte Adams the Raiders wide
receiver he's working with project food
box which we'll talk about here in a
moment we've been talking about uh pump
up songs here
what's the pump up song that you have
before you go out and play a game
pump up song
man I don't know I don't really have a
go-to pump up song I'm usually already
pretty jacked up before I go out there
believe it or not I play a little Erykah
Badu or something something soothing
something that kind of calms me down
before I go out and then maybe maybe
you'll hear some Migos or some some uh
some Mozzy for the Bay Area guys or you
know maybe I'm playing some J Cole or
something like that I don't I don't
really need any crazy type of music to
get me going because my my heart rate is
usually going pretty crazy before for
the game even gets there I like that
okay so you have calm down music yeah
yeah I like I like r b throughout the
day just to kind of keep me level and
then I might spike it up right before we
go out or play something over the
speakers in the locker room or something
like that
um at the last minute what's the oddest
place you've ever been recognized
well that's a great question the oddest
place
I would say in a
convenience store in Medellin Colombia
okay
how did that work I mean walk me through
it here
well
um I was on a trip out there one of my
best friends he was teaching English out
there so he was uh right right out of
college we all did our own thing I
obviously went to the Packers and he
went to uh to Columbia was teaching
English course out there and I was out
there with him on like a I think it was
like a Friday night or something we were
um
of age so we were grabbing a nice adult
beverage
um and uh yeah I mean I'm in one of the
one of the aisles in this guy's like I
mean he's speaking just obviously I mean
it's like 90 probably five percent
Spanish out there I mean it's not a lot
of English this guy's talking to
somebody and he hits a corner and he
literally stops in his tracks
immediately looks at me and he says
Devonte Adams
and that's one of the reasons I love it
so much out there is that it's so good
for my social anxiety I can kind of move
around like a normal you know human
being and go to the grocery store and do
stuff like that so when he did that it
kind of kind of like threw me off a
little bit because I wasn't really ready
to be recognized especially in that
moment I've been recognized out there
before but it was like maybe 9 30 at
night and it just literally like three
people in this small store and this guy
wrecked up but the social anxiety how
does that how does that affect you when
you're playing uh you know games being
interviewed people want to talk to you
before or after a game yeah how do you
get how do you manage that
for me it's it really doesn't Spike or I
don't really feel it in unless it's a
situation where
I I feel like I'm I'm I'm trying to live
and be amongst the commoners and and you
know a situation where if I'm at a game
or dealing with media and stuff like
that I'm already anticipating that so it
really doesn't do the same thing but you
know if I'm in Vegas I can't just go
into you know the wind shops or the you
know go to the mall or something like
that that's when my social anxiety is
going crazy because I'm in a place where
people have a lot of access to me and
it's not Forest you know a particular
reason it's more for you know they just
have the the free access to come up and
talk to me ask me questions and things
like that which I love to do but you
know it's a little different when you're
in a public place and everybody can come
from all different angles but how is it
different in Green Bay
to be honest it wasn't very much
different it was uh in Green Bay the
difference is you have uh more football
fanatics so it's like a a sense of
um you know our football hero and it's
it's more of just that so when they you
know would come across them it was more
like you know a sense of like a family
thing but in Vegas it's the different
types of fans you got people that don't
care at all about football but they just
know you as a figure they see you know
the Billboards on the strip and all that
stuff so it's more of like a more
intense type of interaction than what it
was in Green Bay it's Devonte Adams and
uh he's working with a project food box
an organization helping hunger
non-profits deliver fresh produce to uh
underserved communities in fact you're
getting ready to do that now how did you
get involved in this
well got connected through my marketing
guy with the with the the you know the
great man that runs this
um and had the opportunity to talk to
him
um and and started with the my cleat my
cause
um collaboration I did and kind of
turned into a little bit more just
because it was kind of the organic
um you know
interaction and it just it kind of Hit
the home with me because growing up I
didn't have those type of that type of
access to you know food banks where you
could literally have you know fresh
groceries and and you know healthy foods
not just stuff people can drop enough
stop dropping off stuff at the door but
it's more customized and catered to your
diet and what you
um what you need specifically so when
when I think about helping people that
are less fortunate and then also being
able to give them the top-notch things
you know because these these farmers get
connected with these food banks and it's
it's fresh from the source so having
those type of things to where it's you
know we're not dropping off cookies and
a bunch of just discarded goodies it's
it's really good stuff that's that's
great for cooking and you know just
um directly eating as well so that kind
of hit home for me and it was kind of a
no-brainer it's called project food box
and he'll be visiting a food bank in
Vegas today when's the last time you
talked to Josh Jacobs
um
talk to Josh Jacobs uh recently it was
probably maybe about three or four days
ago
what did you say
you know I just I just told him keep his
head um you know this is my 10th year
now I've been through the the contract
process
um a total of three times now
um you know it's a little easier when
you first come in and once you start
doing your thing on the field and then
makes things a little bit more
interesting come contract time so
basically just told them I understand
where he's coming from you know you
gotta you gotta do what you have to do
um you know in order to
um you know feel your your worth and you
can't just do something that your
heart's not in so at the end of the day
if it doesn't make sense to you you got
to do what you got to do
um but at the same time I try to present
all the things to them that you know the
positives is coming back
um you know he and I are really close so
when it comes to the the connection and
you know I just try to remind them of
the opportunities we have to potentially
do something special together and
um I also let them know that you know I
play with a great deal of running backs
really good running backs and there's
only a handful that I can tell I could
go to literal war with and he's one of
those guys
um so when I think about winning the
Super Bowl and what it takes to win one
you know because I haven't done that yet
I think about having a guy like him you
know in the backfield
um you know by my side another dog
that's ready to to go to war and and do
whatever it takes to get it done I mean
one of the toughest guys I've ever been
around
um and you'll mean
the growth that I saw obviously didn't
know him very well before this um not
having been around him as much but the
growth that I saw from the previous year
to this last year
um you know I don't I don't ever want to
take credit for anything but I know that
when when you get around other people
that are that are like you or that push
you it kind of brings the best out of
you which is kind of the Aaron Rodgers
effect with me I feel like having Aaron
early in my career
um his mindset is work ethic and
um yeah honestly the work ethic is is
through the roof but like I said just
the way he thinks about the game the way
he approaches it
um they put so much of of the way he
does it you know into into my craft and
I was able to kind of steal a few things
and I think the same thing happened with
with both of them you know me and Josh
you know I feel like he helped me with
some of that stuff and it was great
having another dog next to me out there
um and and vice versa so try to just
give him as much as I can without trying
to steer his mind anywhere because I
know what that process is like and I
know what it's like when you know you're
you're going back and forth with a club
about numbers and all those things so
don't want to be be naive in a situation
but also want to make sure that he
um is aware of everything that comes
with it and also
um you know the opportunity that we have
together
what's your favorite Aaron Rodgers story
well I have my favorite but I can't
share that one so that's the one I want
to hear
if you want me and Aaron to look our
friendship has we've sustained it and
we've got a good job of even maybe
kicking it up to a new level oh okay all
right okay so if you want if you want to
keep that intact and no issues then I
cannot share one of them it's not even
that bad it's just a it's just a story
that kind of got to stay within the team
and if he ever sees this okay fair
enough
second best Aaron Rodgers story that
you'll be telling your grandkids
um
well I'll tell you the story this was
this was a veteran in a rookie store
um
it's not that crazy but it but it is it
just shows you the intensity and kind of
what I was just referring to
um so Aaron Rodgers my
I believe it was week two of 2014 my
rookie year
um week one we play Seattle opening of
the season and I think I played like
eight plays so I didn't really get too
much action that day
um so week two against the Lions in
Detroit
we're in that crazy stadium and crazy
things happening there so you know I've
done everything about as good as you
could I was in my book like like no
other rookie in the world and um you
know we have we have we have signals we
use signals a lot over there you guys
saw us let him looking over give me a
signal something quick so we had a
signal that was basically like
this and then we had a signal that was
like this
so that and that so
looks over to me and
and to his in his defense
I technically should have known which
one it was because well they're very
similar looking though Devon very
similar this and and a key in in that
one looked very similar so at the line
he's saying going through the Cadence
green 19 and in between he throws one of
those signals out there my brain just
starts doing backflips and crashing in
the walls all types of stuff so I I
freak out and I just pick one so I don't
even think of the fact that I need
another person with me to do the the
other one though the one that I did so I
do the wrong thing and I run a slant he
throws a little quick quick screen to me
obviously I don't catch this ball the
corner follows me the ball flies out of
bounds it was like goes to like third
down or something he comes sprinting
over to me basically during the game
like just just let me have it and and
Dominican soon looked over at him it was
so awkward like they didn't even they
can't even make fun so he looks over
because I'm so confused like what do you
mean I didn't even in my head I'm like I
did the right thing and he's going off
on me he's like and I tell him and what
what the worst thing that you can do in
a situation is is to just tell him talk
back what you were thinking like you
know I mean like like you just you just
gotta say my bad like that's gonna be
especially as a young guy especially you
know 10 years ago or whatever that was
so
this man runs over there and does that
and indomie can sue looks at him looks
at me as we're like right all next to
each other now and he goes ooh you in
trouble
and that was like one of the worst
feelings I've ever had on the field and
I couldn't say anything one I can't say
anything because it's in Dominican Sue
and I'm a rookie anyway second I mean I
literally was in trouble and I mean I
couldn't say anything about it so that
was that was probably one of the better
better ones and then
um safe to say I didn't make that
mistake anymore that's good yeah you've
done done well since then uh great to
have you on good luck with the project
uh food box there we appreciate your
time good luck this upcoming season
Devonte thank you boss much appreciated
and it's uh Devonte Adams the Raiders